three-man weave for the power rankings
and i don't know how i feel about it
because i'm used to having one other
person criticize and scrutinize my
rankings of the teams i'm going to get
ganged up on today i can feel it coming
and we're gonna be glad to gang up on
you mike because you know what i haven't
even seen him yet and i can just tell
you this right now you're wrong
all right here we go come on without
further ado then let's get into it the
top 10 after 13 weeks of the nfl season
back at number one and they ain't going
anywhere until they lose a game the
baltimore ravens now it gets interesting
a little shake up in the rest of the top
five because the 49ers and the patriots
both lost i've got the seahawks bumping
up from three to two one spot ahead of
the saints who have gone from five to
three the 49ers dropped from two down to
four the patriots from four down to five
texans up three spots number six packers
hold steady at seven chiefs hold steady
at eight the bill's up one to nine and
the vikings down four spots to ten all
right chris i'll give you the first
crack tell me where it's wrong tell me
where it's right well i don't know if i
look at anything and say it's totally
wrong i mean i i like a lot of things i
probably would have still put the 49ers
above the saints for now i understand
why you didn't because they come off a
loss and the saints haven't lost in a
few weeks so that's why you do it but my
feeling still is that the 49ers are a
little bit better so i want you to
explain yourself on that all right and
then the other one is
you know what is it going to take for
the bills to get up there with
you know to number six in front of teams
that don't have as good a record for
them that would be just the two things i
want to ask you about you know what it's
going to take you know it's going to
take beat the ravens this week you beat
the ravens this week and you'll be in
the top five okay peter
you know look mike my biggest thing and
i can't argue with anything other than
i'll argue with one thing new england
patriots should should be number eight
and six seven and eight right now should
all move up one spot
because what we saw the other night is
not going away
and what we saw the other night is the
inability to make any plays on offense
now they made some plays late on offense
and i'm hey look it was 28 to 9. you're
right yeah go ahead i am not
putting dirt on the patriots yet
absolutely unequivocally not however
right now
the green bay packers the houston texans
and the kansas city chiefs today right
now all on a neutral field would beat
the new england patriots that's why they
should be five six and seven and the
patriots should be eight
yeah and the thing about the patriots i
think they want us to throw dirt on them
they want to hear they're done they need
that from time to time to give them a
little kick in the butt and i think
enough people are saying it or or they
can just claim that people are saying it
they've done that in the past as well
nobody believes in us everybody believed
in you last year tom yeah but fewer
people believe in them this year and
it's hard though they got 10 wins and
and it comes down to the schedule the
schedule's been easy that quarterback
graveyard that we showed on the nbc
broadcast sunday night a bunch of guys
that plenty of teams if they had the
opportunity to play that guy would beat
that guy and the patriots indeed did
let's move on to the next ten the
steelers holding steady at number 11 i
couldn't find a spot for them in the top
10 because they are seven and five even
though they got the big win over the
browns they're still there at number 11.
they're still clinging to their playoff
hopes in the afc at number 12 the titans
and again i didn't know where to move
them huge win over the colts but there's
nowhere up at the at the very top of the
second ten rams up four to number 13
after shredding the arizona cardinals
they're also seven and five cowboys fall
one to number fourteen bears get five
bumps but
look i know the bears haven't played
anybody but they're in position to make
something happen now they've won two
games in a row and the other teams that
they jumped haven't the raiders down two
to number 16 colts at number 17 they're
down two spots bucks get bumped four
spots number 18. the browns are down
three to 19 and the eagles drop two
spots to number 20. peter what do you
think of those
you know 16 through 20 can we just
you know
gigantic
blanket of meh
over
16 through 20. i mean how do you like
any of those teams right now the raiders
look really good and they've lost the
last two games by a combined score of
nine million to three
and
you know so at some point you are what
your record says you are
and those teams the only thing i would
say to you mike is
16 through 20 if you had had them 25
through 30 i couldn't argue with you
yeah it is i mean it is an uninspiring
list the one team i still look at there
though through 16 through 20 a little
bit is the colts i mean if they could
just get t y hilton back and paris
campbell back and some guys like that
they'd have a chance and of course you
know their field goal kicking is killing
them i mean it's killing them there's no
other way to say it you know it's again
it was uh you know what is it three
missed field goals i know two of them
were blocked last week it's those issues
uh the other one i find interesting and
and i want to hear what you guys think i
don't know what to think of the
tennessee titans the tennessee titans
you know i look at them and go they're
not screwing games up that's for sure
they are running the ball better uh but
their defense is good not great the
offense is just solid they just never
die and it's unbelievable and two of
their last three games they've won off
of blocked field goals i mean i don't
know if that's sustainable so i'm like
that's a team where i don't know how to
feel about the tennessee titans right
now they're seven and five good for them
mike vrable they fight uh but i just
don't know how talented or how good of a
football team they really are
yeah but the fact that they have a
special team they have to have a special
teams coordinator that has these guys
believing they can block field goals and
the flip side is i mean in indianapolis
between clinging to adam vinatieri
clinging to the special teams
coordinator at some point you got to
start firing people if you want to make
your team better and if the colts don't
make it to the playoffs they can blame
their inability to make extra points and
field goals as the reason for their
failure to get there and that's
unforgivable in today's nfl
look adam vinatieri this year has
missed 14 that means you're missing more
than one kick
per week
that's that is shocking in today's
football that's
1956 football missing a kick a week in
the nfl it's it's stunning and and look
one thing about tennessee i would say
i agree their special teams have done a
lot for them but do you realize the last
three weekends they've played
derrick henry has been the leading
rusher in the nfl every week
they have a quarterback now who can
manage the game and complete 73 of his
of his throws so you've got to respect
that a little bit definitely and you've
got you've got a running game right now
that is is overpowering yeah absolutely
overpowering i don't care how you score
points
but when you're averaging in the mid 30s
and you're the tennessee titans i
thought they'd have to play a month to
score in the 30s and right now their
last three games 35 42 31
that is the recipe for success run the
ball bludgeon teams make a play or two
every week on special teams
i mean it doesn't really matter how you
win they're just winning and they're
beating decent teams they beat kansas
city yeah and they beat indianapolis no
i know i hear you
and here's the thing about the titans
they've got coming up at the raiders the
next to the last or as chris would say
when he's feeling fancy or no this was
big cat on friday penultimate game ever
played at the oakland college
big cat did big cat whipped it out on
friday the penultimate game at the
oakland coliseum that's the titans and
then they've got texans saints texans to
end the season and they're currently on
the outside looking in here's the thing
though about the titans and mds made
this point yesterday in the pft pm week
13 awards podcast because i gave ryan
tannehill the player of the week prize
for the same reasons we're looking at
the cults saying why in the hell aren't
they getting rid of adam vin and terry
or getting rid of their special teams
coordinator you look at the titans and
say why the hell didn't they bench
marcus mariota a lot sooner than they
did because look at how well it's gone
and maybe if they had made the decision
sooner they would be the five seed right
now not trying to scratch and claw to
get to the sixth seat chris yeah i mean
hey mike you know i've been on the ryan
tannehill train ever since they signed
him in tennessee uh you know he's he's a
better version of marcus mariota that's
what he is and you know good for you for
giving an award because the one thing
when i turn on tennessee titan film
every week that really jumps out to me
and this is a big stat to me is what was
there to be had and did you take full
advantage of it and every week even
though the stats aren't sexy because
they don't have game breaking receivers
or that type of creativity in the
offensive passing game i come away going
man there wasn't a lot of people wide
open but he made the most of every
single pass play and when there was a
guy open by a sliver on a deep post or
something like that man he stripes it in
there every time he has been the
difference for their football team
because they you know to what you guys
have said peter and mike you know they
play they play defense they play special
teams they run the ball and then they
just needed a few pass plays every game
to get them over the hump and he's
providing that and he's showing he's
worthy of being the starting quarterback
there
it is amazing when you look at his
career and how many struggles he had
with miami and he was kind of a work in
progress he'd been converted from
receiver to quarterback before he was
the eighth overall pick he was ascending
in 2016 had the knee injury and then it
it went the rest of the way in the 2017
training camp and and now it's all
falling together and peter as you
pointed out he's completing nearly 73 of
his passes and chris it's because he's
delivering the ball to the right guy
he's making the right decision and he's
delivering it accurately that's how you
complete three out of four of your
passes peter and and uh you know again
they're on the outside looking in right
now they need the steelers to falter and
they've got some tough games but man
this this is one of those teams that
falls into that category of i don't want
them showing up in the divisional round
if i'm the team that's been off for a
week and they're
rolling through that momentum and
they've won a wild card game that's
going to be a tough team to beat if they
make it that far
you know the other thing i want to give
credit to with tennessee is the fact
that john robinson
learned something when he worked as a
scout in the patriots organization under
bill belichick and scott pioli and that
is that one of the most important things
that you can do
is happens on uh on day three of the
draft and not just the fourth through
seventh rounds
but
in what you do
in undrafted free agency
what did they do the other day
what won the game for him i mean there
were a bunch of things that won the game
but
look at the people who won those the
guys on the special teams yeah this guy
named crookshank you know and how about
this
undrafted free agent wide receiver
khalif raymond from the football
powerhouse of holy cross in worcester
massachusetts he makes a fantastic catch
diving catch in the end zone from ryan
tannehill and so
he understands john robinson understands
that
at some point down the stretch of a
season bill parcells always used to say
at some point in the year the 46th 48th
50th guy on your roster is gonna win a
game you really need to win if you're a
good team that's gonna happen
and that is what happened the other day
to tennessee so this has really been an
interesting team effort for the titans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports